[Music]
were there any like failures from a
marketing perspective that you had I
would say a couple of things to that
first you know I again I I was in
advertising before so I sort of always
had this theory that unless we you know
could really get the frequency that it
wasn't worth it so you know we didn't we
never really it's like went out and
bought one billboard because I just
thought it like one billboard it just do
anything right it's just wasting money
if we're if we're just doing one thing
and so I think that we've always
believed like you know buy it by a chunk
in an area and you know do do it right
or just don't do it at all and that sort
of been our theory too that you know
just just not only from a marketing
district marketing brand standpoint but
also from a distribution standpoint
we've also just believed like if we
can't actually do well in a store or in
a market like we shouldn't be there
right and I think it's the same sort of
philosophy for like don't be afraid to
take your time and which is sort of like
you know not what everybody would say
like I mean we've had so many you know
brands that have said no you got to get
across the u.s. you got to get into the
Kroger you got to get a Publix like
Costco fast fast fast and so many of
those companies aren't here anymore
because we just spent too fast right so
if you don't have the money to go into
those markets and really do it right I
mean my best advice would be you know
just do the markets they you can be
really good at well period
[Music]